[موسيقى]
تسمح لنا المقاييس بالتحقيق بشكل
أعمق في تاريخ الثوران
حتى نتمكن من
فهم سبب توقف الانفجار بأثر رجعي
وهذا هو أهم شيء بالنسبة
للتنبؤات المستقبلية ،
لذا لن أعلق على  سواء كنا
نعتقد أنه سيتوقف لأنه
من الصعب للغاية معرفة أفضل طريقة
للنظر إلى هذه الأشياء هي المراقبة النشطة
للزلازل
وكيمياء الغاز أم حجم التيفرا
والرماد الذي يتم
إنتاجه وعندما تبدأ هذه الأشياء في التباطؤ
تقليل الزلازل يمكننا أن نبدأ
في الاستنتاج على الأقل أن الانفجار البركاني قد
يكون بطيئًا
[موسيقى]
لم يتمكنوا من فعل ذلك
لأنك ستدمر
ملايين المشاكل أو مئات
الخصائص وستدمر ما تعلمونه في الوقت
الحالي  كارثة طبيعية
فظيعة لكنها كارثة طبيعية ،
نعم الجميع يتعلم الكثير
من هذا الانفجار
، إنها فرصة جيدة حقًا
للعمل معًا
و  للجزر لفهم كيفية
إدارة هذا النوع من الأزمات
لك